it's here people the Aquaman trailer the
one we've been waiting for for a while
America's superhero really quick let me
give a shout out to Rosa Parra giving
you a shout out early cuz I know you had
to go to the hospital last week and it's
your birthday in a few days there's
gonna wait to actual birthday but I
wanted to say one of our biggest
trailers just for you to say happy
birthday in advance you don't look a day
over twelve and happy for your 18th
birthday you are the lady Stark of our
channel we love you dearly I hope you
recover well and I hope you don't get
too hammered on your birthday but if you
do your beautiful daughter Cassandra
will take care of you anyway guys
Aquaman
diggin white house it was a lighthouse
keeper
[Music]
dumbasses whoa
love to go over this kid to SeaWorld
[Music]
oh yeah mr. James went directly right
there
Wow
[Music]
that's actually better yeah
Wow
that
Wow
Wow
save my home the people that allowed
you think you're on me to lead because
you're two different worlds
wow that's like manacles
oh yeah
anyone else except ready oh my god not
bad at all with no marble in here today
I feel like DC really took that
opportunity hard yeah they're owning it
right now I mean this is amped ran the
Aqua Metro two very different vibes and
James Wan kept holding off on the
trailer because he kept saying I want
the effects to be finished I want the
effects to look good gotta make a first
impression after seeing this trailer I'm
like no wonder you actually held off on
the effects because this could have
easily looked terrible yes this looks
great this is their most ambitious
visual film the DC has put together
weirdly I got a black panther vibe from
this except instead of Wakanda its water
condom yeah in some ways and a whole
like becoming a king and like learning
to accept the mantle and stuff like we
saw underwater effects in Justice League
I was alright with those yeah and these
looks so much better it looks really
natural you get so much there's crazy
epicness this is a tighter waves and
it's it's thick there's a lot of battle
sequences in here I guess I wasn't
expecting that just a lot of armies
fighting each other
underwater oh yeah and it looks great
it'll even looks after some type of like
gladiator like matches going on looks
like a legit epic in Atlantis yeah like
it makes Atlantis look like this fully
fleshed world yeah and I'm really
excited it's like they keep hyping up
this trench battle I'm excited to see
that I'm excited to see how badass
mirror is gonna be merely looks great
what I love about her here she looks
more than just some you know cool chick
gonna be a huge part very much utilized
it might even be a scene stealer from
Aquaman in the movie and black mana
looks great I would play with Black
Manta when I played in justice yeah and
it's the Sita brought to life here it
looks just like I'm surprised at how
excited those two two shots of him just
firing those laser beams made me for ya
you know and also I mean I'm curious
about Patrick Wilson - he looks really
different looks like the main story of
it
so what's funny to me is all the
underwater stuff and all the crazy
visual stuff looks
amazing and great they really pulled it
off it's just when they're above water
yeah what's kind of weird like in the
daylight yeah yeah I mean I got I got I
do got a nitpick one thing with her wig
whoo and they're like yeah we're playing
I was like yeah that's what it looks a
little bit off the stuff that really
counts looks great yeah what I'm just
excited for what James won this stamp
he's gonna put on this because you get a
lot of personality it looks epic so this
looks like a new scope for him but also
you know I'm sure they're gonna be
Easter eggs you got Leigh Whannell
popping up I'm excited this is easily
gonna be their most ambitious film
they've had to put together thus far
this is their biggest most epic scale
they've ever done it looks and I have a
lot of faith that visually at least
they're really gonna pull it off
performance wise they're really gonna
pull it off now it's just like and James
Wan has such a good track record that I
doubt this movie's you know she's just a
solid film me yeah so even if it's just
all right you know it's gonna be pretty
good already just need to start hiring
only horror director well the new
producer that they have running the ship
I forgot what exact position he has that
replaced Jeff Jones yeah he worked on it
this looks like a great epic fantasy
brought to life
I am excited for him dude DC is killing
it with these tributes go different with
this stuff that's what's going through
very different trailers oh good good you
guys you guys definitely won this year
man all right guys well what do you
think of this Aquaman trailer I mean it
has the right amount of fantastical
cheese that I just enjoy yeah you guys
can subscribe to the reject nation click
that notification Bell check us out on
patreon full-length TV show reactions
weekly q and A's music video covers love
to have you become a patron oject
today I'm gonna go work on my Aquaman
cosplay